So, we're beginning February the 8th, 1915, in Volume 11.
Jesus does not want childish fusses of self-reflections, that's VIP.
Jesus doesn't want us to reflect back on ourselves at all, he wants us to forget ourselves and
to think of him.
So, don't forget that as we're reading this in 1915, World War I is raging and so you'll
hear various things.
So since the war is raging, Jesus is saying that Luisa should not be thinking about her
own privations or whatever else, that there are millions of people out there who desperately
need prayer for their salvation, okay.
So Luisa said, "I continue very afflicted because of the ways my beloved Jesus has with
me, but I'm resigned to his most holy volition.
If I lament to Jesus because of his privations and his silence, he says to me, 'This is not
the time to think about this, the World War is raging, okay.'
These are childish fusses and they're of very weak souls who care about themselves and not
about me."
That's quite a smack on the hand, isn't it?
Okay, in other words he's telling her, this is kindergarten stuff, let's get on with being
spiritual adults.
I want to give you one Corinthians 1311, one Corinthians 1311, where St Paul says, "When
I was a child I taught like a child, but now I'm an adult and I think differently."
So these people, Jesus said, they think of what they feel rather than what they should
be doing.
Now this is a real correction to Luisa.
These souls reek of human to me and I can't trust them.
From you I do not expect this, I want the heroism of the souls who forgetting about themselves
care only about me and united with me occupy themselves with the salvation of my children.
It was millions of them were going to have to be saved from the battlefield or from burnt
out dwellings or bombings or whatever.
These souls care only about me and united with me occupy themselves with the salvation
of my children whom the devil tries to snatch from my arms using all his tricks.
Now of course if it's World War I, some of the tricks that the devil will be using is
how can God be a good God and allow this to happen?
How can you have all this suffering in the world and you're telling us that God is merciful
or God is love?
So the devil keeps twisting everything to turn people away from God.
And for the soldiers in the battlefields the temptation for them would be to despair and
not totally throw themselves into the arms of God.
I want you to adapt yourself to the times.
The times is the World War.
The times which are so sorrowful, so mournful and so tragic, that's Jesus' take on World
War I.
Isn't that interesting?
And I want to pray and cry, I want you to pray and cry together with me.
So you need to put I want you and I want you, the I want you is necessary there.
I want you to pray and to cry together with me over the blindness of people.
That's spiritual blindness, physical blindness is not so much of a problem.
Your life must disappear, in other words your little agenda, okay, must disappear, letting
the whole of my life permeate you.
If you do this I will feel in you the fragrance of my divinity and I will trust you in these
sad times.
And yet these are nothing but the preludes of chastisements, that means preludes of things
to come, in other words there's another World War coming, okay.
And I think those who lived at the time of the First World War couldn't have imagined
another World War, they called it the war to end all wars.
What will happen when things go further, Jesus said, poor children, poor children, okay.
And it seems that Jesus offers so much that he remains speeches.
He hides more deeply than ever inside of my heart.
So to hide in her heart the kingdom of God is within you, that is Luke 17, 21.
And when tired of my sorrowful state I renew my laments, I call him over and over again,
I say to him, Jesus, don't you hear the tragedies that are happening, the extraordinary thing
is considering the marvelous relationship she has with God.
And the number of times he has taken her in and out of the body experience to see what's
going on on the earth, she's saying to him, don't you see it?
That's her saying, why don't you stop her?
And so she hasn't heard, you know, that human beings are doing this absolutely contrary
to God's will.
How is it possible that your compassionate heart can bear so much torment in your children?
He seems to just barely move in my interior as if he didn't want to be heard.
And I feel another panting breath within my breathing.
You see how closely united they are, John 14, 20 to 21, you and me and I and you.
As if I were rattling, that is correct, he's trying to tell her that if she would concentrate
on what he's doing, she would be able to participate more deeply.
That is the breath of Jesus, she said, because I recognize its sweetness.
So this is the new suffering that she's going to have, and it's hard for her to turn around
and adjust to something completely new, okay, that her sufferings are all going to be spiritual
rather than physical.
You find it refreshes me completely, it makes me feel mortal pains because in that breath,
I feel the breath of all.
Now, this is what we've been told all the time.
You fuse yourself into the Lord, and in him you find everybody, isn't that correct?
This is why she can feel Jesus' breath, and she can also, now because she's completely
concentrated on him, feel the breath of all souls.
So she will sense the suffering of the soldiers in the battlefield.
It's very interesting, and that is what will stimulate her to pray and suffer for them.
You see, especially of many dying lives, they're the soldiers in the battlefield.
And Jesus suffers the rattle of agony with them.
Now, this is an image of World War I, you won't get anywhere else.
But Louisa says that entering into him, into Jesus, she was able to, first of all, hear
his agonized breath, and in him, hear the breath of all those soldiers and everybody
else that was suffering in World War I, and that Jesus was suffering with those soldiers
in their dying.
It's where everything is through him, with him, and in him.
Other times it seems that he's in so much pain that he sends out feeble moans as the
dying wood and the fields with nobody around to help them, such as to move the hardest
hearts to pity.
And then I continued my lament, she said, this morning, and he told me, my daughter,
the union of our wills is such that the will of one cannot be distinguished from the will
of the other.
Therefore, he's going to start referring to Louisa as my inseparable Louisa.
Up to now he has only referred to his mother as my inseparable mother, but if the two
wills are one, they're inseparable, isn't that correct?
Okay.
I put John 1511 there.
You cannot distinguish one from the other.
It is this union of will that forms all the perfection of the three divine persons because
since we are equal in the will, this uniformity brings also the uniformity of sanctity, wisdom,
beauty, power, love, and all the rest of our being.
So we reflect ourselves in one another, and our satisfaction in looking at the other is
so great as to render us fully happy.
So each one is reflected in the other, and each one pours into the other all the qualities
of our being like many immense seas of different joys.
If anything were dissimilar among us, our being would not be perfect nor fully happy.
What makes family life difficult is that you can have five persons, five different wills,
and they may be pulling in different directions.
That's what makes it difficult, okay?
And Jesus says that what causes the supreme eternal happiness of the Trinity is that there
is one will, so there's never any dissension.
So Jesus continues.
Now, in creating man, we infused our image and likeness into him.
It's Genesis 1.27, Genesis 1.27, and Genesis 2.7, 1.27, and 2.7.
Genesis 1.27 says let us make man in our own image and likeness, okay?
Genesis 2.7 is God poured the breath of his being and man became a living being, okay?
So it's in the pouring of that breath that this likeness actually comes.
We infused our image and likeness into him so as to overwhelm him with our happiness and
be reflected and delighted in him.
But man broke the first length of the connection which is the will.
Now all the sin is in the will.
And this was the connection between himself and the Creator.
Therefore, he lost true happiness, why?
The happiness would have been in the union of wills, is that okay?
Even more, all evils swooped down upon him.
So we can neither reflect ourselves nor delight in him.
Only in the soul who does our will in every thing, that means 24,7,3,6,5.
Can we do it?
And in her we enjoy the complete fruit of creation.
So this is asking for the final complete union of will.
And if you think it's impossible, you're going to hear a testimony about that not too
distant future.
In fact, even with those who have some virtues, who pray, who attend the sacraments, if they
are not conformed to our will, we cannot reflect ourselves in them.
I call this having a religion but not having a relationship with God.
And unfortunately, it's far too frequent.
So if they're not conformed to our will, we cannot reflect ourselves in them because
since their will is broken from ours, all things are in disorder and upside down.
Reference Ireland.
Correct?
Everything's upside down.
Am I daughter?
Only our will is welcome.
That is into the tense of eternity because it re-orders.
It makes one happy and brings all goods with itself.
So when we start this journey with the divine will, the Lord has to do a major work in each
one of us reordering our way of thinking, our way of being, our way of deciding, our way
of motivating, our way of working, our way of everything.
He's got to reorder the whole thing.
And as you go on in the divine will, this reordering makes you have more and more integrity, more
and more holiness, more and more love, and you feel more and more healthy unless the Lord
gives you something to carry in reparation for others.
Sometimes he does that.
But that reordering is terribly important.
And so one of the keys for recognizing if we're growing in the divine will is that this reordering
is happening in us as Ebenezer Scrooge says, "I'm not the man I was.
I may not know where I am, but I know I'm not that one.
I've moved, things have changed, something has happened."
And so you recognize in whatever dim way you do, God is working in you, "Therefore do
my will always," Jesus said, "and in everything."
You see, the problem we have in the apostasy that's in the church is that people are saying
that they believe in Christ and they believe in everything he revealed, but they just don't
want his morality and religion without morality is monstrous.
And so in saying they believe and at the same time, absolutely rejecting the morality of
the church, they're actually rejecting Christ.
So therefore do my will always and in everything and do not care about anything else.
So Louisa said, "My love and my life, how can I conform to your will with regard to the
scourges you are sending?"
So Louisa is blaming the Lord for World War I.
And it's partially true because he allowed it.
It takes too much to say fear, she says, "And besides, how many times have you told me that
if I did your will, you would do mine, I love this.
I love the way she doesn't let him off with anything.
And now what?
Have you changed?"
And Jesus said, "It's not I who have changed.
It's humanity that has reached the point of becoming unbearable."
I love the word unbearable because then you know why it had to be cleansed with such a
severe cleansing, but beside it, I want you to put Habakkuk 1.13, H-A-B-B, Habakkuk 1.13.
And Habakkuk 1.13 says, "Lord, your eyes are too holy to look upon sin."
"Man has become unbearable," he said, "Come closer and suckle from my mouth the offenses
that they send me.
If you can swallow them," he said, "I will suspend the scourges."
Now, she's challenged him.
He challenges her.
So Louisa said, "I drew near his mouth and suckled with a vidity."
In other words, I tried to get something.
To my highest sorrow, I tried hard to swallow, but I couldn't.
I choked.
And then I returned to try hard again, but I could not manage.
And with the tender voice sobbing, Jesus said, "Have you seen?
You can't swallow it either."
This felt this rot from the human race spewed on the ground, and it will fall on the rest
of humanity.
In other words, Louisa agrees to the chastisements.
Now, when you get to the higher volumes, this is going to be much, much clearer, and she
won't be struggling like this.
This is very new.
Let me just give you an example from the Old Testament that'll make it maybe slightly
more familiar for you.
When Moses was on the mountain talking to God for 40 days and 40 nights, in the dialogue
that he had with God, God said to him, "You know, your people down there, they've apostasized,
and they've committed this great sin.
In my presence, under my nose."
And then Moses said, "Well, you know, they're only starting, and they're only weak.
The way the mother would say to the father, if she's defending the child, is, "He's only
a kid, you know, and the father said, "No, he needs to be disciplined.
You know what I mean?"
And so Moses was defending them, and defending them, and defending them.
And then God says, "Will you miss?
We'll go down."
So Moses goes down in the mountain, and when he actually sees what they're doing, he punishes
them.
And I'm sure God was sitting there laughing.
It's just that he didn't see what was going on, but when Moses saw the reality of what
was going on on the ground, he behaved in a way that utterly amazes you, executed the
leaders, absolutely no question, get rid of this rod, cut it out, we have to start all
over again.
Now, if God told him to do it, he'd have resisted, it's very interesting.
And so, Louisa had to experience what Jesus was experiencing from all the rot coming
off from the earth.
And when there was no way she could take it, if he couldn't take it, of course, he couldn't
take it.
It was only then.
She said, "I couldn't do it, so it's very interesting."
So Louisa said, "I spewed this stuff."
And Jesus too spewed it from his mouth down to the earth saying, "This is nothing yet.
This is nothing yet."
In other words, we haven't seen the worst of the justicement.
It's only 1915.
And he disappeared.
So March the 6th, 1915, the background of the message, once you keep it clear in your
head that the background of the message is World War I, then it's going to make sense.
Louisa said, "As I was in my usual state, my beloved Jesus came for a little while.
Since my confessor was not well, and therefore my state had been interrupted."
Now, this means that Jesus has insisted, you remember, since Volume 1, that when Louisa
comes out of her ecstatic state, the priest is to come and bless her.
And that releases her from the stiffness that she experiences.
Do you remember that?
So that's what she means.
My state has been interrupted.
So it's not like before, when I would come around when called by obedience.
And I said to Jesus, "What do you want me to do?
Should I stay, or should I try to come around when I feel free?"
And Jesus answered, "My daughter, do you perhaps want me to operate as before, when
I not only commanded you to remain in this state understood, but I also bound you in
such a way that you could not come around if not through obedience?
If I did this now, my love would feel constrained, and my justice would find an obstacle in pouring
itself out fully upon humanity."
Isn't that interesting?
And you might say to me, "Just as you keep me bound as a victim of sufferings for love
of you and for love of humanity, so do I bind you in order to stop your justice from pouring
itself out upon creatures."
What would the result be?
The wars and the preparations that other nations are making to go to war, and I can't
you see that in March 1915 it hadn't yet become a world war.
Other nations were just thinking of joining.
The preparations that other nations are making to go to war would all go up and smoke.
"I cannot," he said, "I cannot at the most if you want to remain in this state, or if
the confessor wants to keep you in it, I will have some regard for Corrato."
Now this means the tiny little place that she's living in.
That's a pinprick in Italy, and so Corrato is such a tiny pinprick in Italy that it would
have no effect on the whole thing, and he said, "I'd spare something."
But meanwhile things are getting tighter and my justice does not want you in this state
at all, so as to be able to send more scourges immediately.
Make other nations go to war and the issue is to lower the pride of humanity.
That's the issue.
Now there's a very important chapter 2 of Isaiah verses 6 to 22 when in the context
of the people of Israel, the chosen people, they were in trouble in the 6th century, before
8th century, before Christ, and Isaiah in this chapter repeats over and over again the pride
of man must be brought low.
The real thing behind pride is independence of God, you'll do your own thing.
We have it in song, "I did it my way."
Try not to write on the table.
I did it my way, that's the big tragedy, because if pride is what's guiding us, well
the spirit of pride is Satan.
That means we give Satan open door to guide humanity.
That's why pride has come down, and there's lots of texts I've given you before on bringing
down the pride of man, the one I remember just now is 1 Peter 5 and I think it's 5 to 9,
bow down before the power of God now and he will raise you up.
We have the magnificat of our blessed lady that he pulls the mighty from their thrones
and raises up the lowly.
We have lots of proverb saying that God always resists the proud and always favors the humble.
There's lots of them, but I'm not going to go down that route now, is that okay?
What Jesus is saying is that the issue as far as God is concerned in World War I is to
lower the pride of humanity.
We have to lower the pride of humanity and so they will find defeats where they thought
they were going to find victories, I'll ask my love cries and my justice demands satisfaction
might offer, he said, have patience and he disappeared, but Louisa said, who can say
how I felt I felt I was dying because I thought that if I had gone out of this state by myself,
I myself might be the cause for an increase in discourages and therefore for the entrance
of other nations and to war, especially of Italy.
Not pain, what heartbreak.
I felt all the weight of this suspension from Jesus and I thought to myself, who knows whether
Jesus is not permitting the confessor to be well so as to give the final blow and make
Italy enter the war.
She is realizing that there's no coincidences.
The fact that the priest is not well and is not available to her is actually part of the
disposing of the situation.
How many suspicions and fears she said, and I came out of that state by myself and I spent
days of tears and of intense bitterness, but the tears and the intense bitterness are
all part of the reparation that she's got to make.
So March the 7th, 1915, of course it's justices and the children of the church will be her
own fiercest enemies.
Please take note, that is what's ahead for all of us.
People who were Catholics alongside us in the pews will persecutions because the time is
coming when the two roads are going to separate.
The thought of discourages and of the fact that I might foment them by going out of this
state by myself pierced my heart.
The confessor continued not to be well, I prayed and I cried and I could not make up
my mind.
Blessed Jesus would come like a flash and run away leaving me free.
That is free to decide one way or the other.
That's a bigger problem for her than anything else because you can make a wrong decision.
Whereas if the confessor is there and she's under obedience, she's not going to make a
mistake because she's been told to treat the confessor as if he was Christ.
So finally moved to compassion, Jesus came and sympathizing with me and caressing all
of me, he said, and this whole piece now is the power of love and prayer.
Very important, the power of love and prayer.
My daughter, your constancy conquers me.
So that means she continues to pray and to make reparation regardless of how she is.
Love and prayer bind me and almost wage battle against me.
Therefore I have come to be with you for a little while for I couldn't resist anymore.
Poor daughter, do not cry, here I am all for you.
It's not amazing.
There's a world war going on and the Lord comes just for her.
It's absolutely amazing.
Patients, courage, don't lose heart.
If you knew how much I suffer but the ingratitude of souls forces me to do this.
They're enormous sins.
Now these are his words.
They're incredulity, almost wanting to challenge me.
Now you need to put beside that atheism which has been spreading since the beginning of
the 20th century.
And this is the least.
If I told you about the religious side, how many sacrileges, how many rebellions, how
many pretend to be my children while they are my fiercest enemies, in other words modern
judicists.
Now the ones who are pretending to be children and are fierce enemies are the ones who are
still attending church, but in fact they've gone over to atheism, Marxism, atheism or
pre-Masonry.
Okay.
And in other words, they wear a sheep, and now they're not sheep, but they're still
in the fold.
These false sons are usurpers, self-interested and incredulous.
Their hearts are bilges of vice.
These very sons will be the first to wage war against the church, and they will try to
kill their own mother.
Their own mother is the church of course.
Oh, how many of them are already about to go out into the field.
That means to go out into the public.
Now there is war among governments and countries.
Soon they will make war against the church.
Our greatest enemies will be her own children.
That's Matthew 1038, Matthew 1038, your enemies will be those of your own household.
Okay.
Now I want to give you an example of that, although I would have said it to you before,
and that is a Jewish man called Weishwacht was his surname, German, became Christian,
then he became Catholic, then he became a priest, then he rejected the priesthood, then
he rejected Catholicism, and then he rejected Christianity, and then he founded the Illuminati.
And the Illuminati, the Illuminati are much worse than Freemasonry.
And Freemasonry wasn't as bad as it is now until they were infiltrated by the Illuminati.
So there was one who was absolutely in the heart of the church, now the fiercest enemy
of the church.
But Jesus is illustrated.
He wasn't the only one, but he's a very Adam Weishwacht was his name.
But he's one of the most famous of them, is that okay?
So her greatest enemies will be her own children.
My heart is lacerated with sorrow.
But in spite of all this, I will let this storm pass by.
The face of the earth and the churches will be washed by the blood of the same ones who
have smeared them and contaminated them.
So an awful lot of people will die.
So for that I want to give you Revelation 11, 18.
For the bit I've just read that the earth and the churches turn it off.
The earth and the churches will be washed with the blood of those very ones who have
tried to destroy it.
That's Revelation 11, 18, which says, I will destroy the destroyers of the earth.
You too unite yourself to my sorrow, he said, pray and be patient in watching this storm
pass by.
So for that I want to give you Isaiah 26, 20.
And Matthew 6, 6, just to be very still in him and watch it.
6, but Louisa said, who can say my torment?
I felt I was more dead than alive, may Jesus be always blessed and may his holy will be
always done.
So April the 3rd, 1915, the divine will is like heaven and sun for the soul.
That's great to get out of the adjustments and into divine will, okay.
My beloved Jesus continues to come every now and then, but without changing his appearance
of threats and scourges.
And if sometimes he delays, he comes with an appearance that moves on to pity, tired
and exhausted.
He draws me to himself and transforms me into himself.
Look at that.
There's your fusing, okay.
And he enters into me and transforms himself into me.
So there's your John 14, 20 to 21 again, you in me and I in you.
Yeah, look what's going on, he transforms me into himself and then he transforms himself
into me.
The word we use for that much more commonly is come union, Jesus and me, we come together.
We have it in holy communion, okay.
He wants me to kiss his wounds one by one and to adore them and to repair.
Now you meet that several times in the hours of the passion where she's doing the adoration
to the whole body of Christ and making reparation.
And in doing that she's actually making reparation for all the wounds of the church, okay.
And then afterwards he, after he has made me soothe his most holy humanity, he tells
me, my daughter, my daughter, it's necessary that I come to you every now and then to take
rest and to be suited.
Now when she's doing adoration to the various parts of the humanity of Christ, he's actually
getting her to make reparation for all kinds of stuff in the church.
That's actually what he's getting her to do.
He said, I pour myself out, otherwise I would cause the world to be devoured by fire.
Look at that.
Now two Peter three ten tells us that in the end the world will be devoured by fire.
Two Peter three ten.
The world will be devoured by fire in the end.
So another way of saying what Jesus has just said is I'd finish it all off.
I'd be quit with the whole thing.
And without giving me time to tell him anything he escapes.
Now because he doesn't want her intercessions, you see, it's necessary to have the chastised
land.
So this morning, as I was in my usual state, since he was delaying, I thought to myself,
what would have happened to me during these privations of my sweet Jesus if it wasn't
for the holy divine will?
Who would have given me life, strength and help?
She's asking a very good question.
"O holy divine will," she said, "in you, I enclose myself."
Please call her this.
This has to be your prayer.
"O holy divine will, in you, I enclose myself.
In you, I abandon myself.
In you, I rest."
Now, that's one of the best prayers you can pray.
"O holy divine will, in you, I enclose myself.
In you, I abandon myself.
In you, I rest."
All run away from me, even suffering.
She means external sufferings, because it's going to take Louisa quite a bit of time to
admit that the internal sufferings are more important and that they're more powerful.
And even that very Jesus who once seemed unable to be without me, he runs away as well.
You alone, that is the divine will, do not escape me.
"O please, I beg you, when you see that my weak strength, there should be no 'S' there
in English, can take no more, reveal to me my sweet Jesus, whom you hide from me, and
whom you possess.
O holy volition, I adore you, I kiss you, I thank you, but don't be cruel with me.
I love that."
So while I was thinking and praying this, I felt myself being invested, look at this,
by a most pure light, now that is the divine will.
Look at the prayer she has just said, which I repeated several times, okay?
And the answer is that the divine will comes to her in a completely new way.
I was invested, her whole being filled.
And the holy divine volition of Jesus, sorry, and the holy volition revealing Jesus to me
told me.
Now the most pure light is one Timothy 616, one Timothy 616, God dwells in unapproachable
light.
And then one John, one five, God is light.
So God dwells in unapproachable light, and God is light.
So the next paragraph is all about the heaven of the divine will.
My daughter, the soul without my will would have been like the earth.
That it had neither heavens, nor stars, nor sun, nor moon.
The earth in itself is nothing.
It's nothing other than precipices and steep heights and waters and darkness.
In other words, rocks and water.
If the earth did not have a heaven above, which shows man the way, so that he may recognize
the different dangers which the earth contains, man would be bound to fall or to drown at
et cetera.
In others, we need the light of the sun to be actually able to negotiate our way.
But there is a heaven above, and especially a sun, which says to man in mute language,
see, I have no eyes or hands or feet, and yet I am the light of your eyes, the action
of your hand, and the step of your foot.
And when I have to illuminate other regions, I leave you the sparkling of the stars and
the moonlight to continue my office.
Now, just as I gave to man a heaven for the good of his nature, to his soul too, which
is more noble, I gave the heaven of my will.
As the soul too contains precipices and heights and cracks, and there are passions and virtues
and tendencies and other stuff.
Now, if the soul moves out from under the heaven of my will, she will do nothing but
fall from sin to sin, passions will drown her, and the heights of virtue will turn into
a business.
Put beside that John 15, 5.
Put me, you can do nothing.
We keep falling.
Therefore, just as everything would be disordered and infertile on the earth without a heaven,
it's the same with the soul without my will.
Very, very good description as to why we absolutely leave the divine will, you know, it would
be utter chaos.
So April the 24th, 1915.
Finding myself in my usual state, I was thinking of how much blessed Jesus suffered in being
crowned with thorns.
So here again we have the hours of the passion, okay?
She often comes back to them because she's doing it on a daily basis.
And making himself seen Jesus told me, "My daughter, the pains which
I suffered were incomprehensible to the created mind."
I think that's absolutely true.
And no matter what commentary you read, it's just incomprehensible to the created mind.
Much more painfully than these thorns, my mind was pierced by all the evil thoughts
of creatures.
Now beside that, I want you to put Proverbs 23.7, Proverbs 23.7, as a man thinks, so is
he.
Or as we would say in modern English, you are what you think.
That's why it's good to examine what we're thinking.
My mind, he said, was pierced by all the evil thoughts of creatures in such a way that none
of these thoughts could escape me.
I felt them all inside of me.
So I felt not only the thorns, but also the disgust for these sins which those thorns
inflicted on me.
There's two things.
You have the actual physical reality and what is actually represented.
So you have the outward passion and the inward passion.
The inward passion is much worse.
Louisa said, "I looked at my beloved Jesus and I could see his most holy head surrounded
by spokes of thorns which came out from inside of him."
Now if they come from inside, it's the thoughts of our hearts.
All the thoughts of creatures were in Jesus.
They went from Jesus into them and from them into him, remaining as though linked together
and how much he suffered.
You can see therefore the folly when Christians will go to confession and not actually confess
the things they need to confess and try and tell the confesser that they're grand.
They'll give the impression that they're grand.
And the confesser will say, "Why did you come to me?"
We know the logic that if you go to a doctor and you're fine, he'll say, "Well, did you
mind?
I'm busy.
Can I get the next patient?
I want the ones that are sick."
And in the same way in the confessional, the only thing the Lord wants are the people
who are sick and will acknowledge it and let him deal with it and let him heal us.
And so every now and then you hear him saying in these writings that the sacrileges that
go on in the sacraments, that sometimes it's worse to go to a sacrament when you're going
to sin more.
It's amazing.
Things are not what they've seen.
So then the next paragraph then is very important.
Jesus added, "My daughter, only the souls who live in my will can give me true reparation."
Now therefore put a heading on this paragraph, "True reparation."
There's reparation and there's true reparation.
It can suit me from thorns that are so sharp, in fact, since they live in my will and since
my will is everywhere, they find themselves in me, see fused in him or fused in him and
we find him, we find everything, so, sorry, since they live in my will and my will is everywhere,
they find themselves in me and in everyone.
That's one thing I love about the divine will, that fusing into him, we can actually help
people from within, which is really, really incredible.
And they descend into souls and they rise up to me, they bring me all the reparations,
they soothe me and in creatures' minds they turn darkness into light.
That's a terribly important thing which we could discuss later if you want.
So May the 2nd, 1915, the pains of Jesus, we are talking about the pains of Jesus because
of the chastisement, and the souls who live in the divine will are the closest to the humanity
of Jesus, they live in him and in all creatures.
And this is the bit that we're moving into, that you can actually reach all creatures in
him, with him and through him in the divine will and therefore, just think of Louisa sitting
in her bed, apparently doing nothing.
And once she's fused into the divine will and she unites her reparations with the reparations
of Jesus, she's making absolute infinite reparation for all these poor soldiers who are dying
out in the fields, all over the world without even knowing does anybody helping them.
Isn't it fascinating that we can reach absolutely everybody everywhere, you know.
It's one of the aspects of the divine will thing I absolutely love.
Louisa says, "My days are more and more so very bitter.
This morning my sweet Jesus came in such a state of suffering that it cannot be described.
On seeing him suffer so much," so that means of course something new drastic has happened
on the earth, okay, "on seeing him suffer so much I would have wanted to give him relief
at any cost.
Not knowing what to do, I pressed him to my heart and drawing near his mouth with mine,
I tried to suckle part of his interior bitterness," now notice what she's looking for.
She's looking for what he's experiencing on the inside, but it was nothing.
No matter how hard I tried to suckle, nothing would come out.
I returned to my efforts but was all in vain.
Jesus was crying and I too was crying and see that I could not alleviate his pains in
any way.
It was a cruel torment.
Jesus was crying because he wanted to pour his bitterness into me, but his justice prevented
him from doing it.
So here you've got the battle between love and justice.
As a parent you will have experienced this, that on the one hand you feel that if a child
is not disciplined, that child is not going to become the well-balanced adult that you
want them to be.
And on the other hand you absolutely hate causing the distress, am I right?
That's the balance between love and justice.
I was crying and seeing him cry because I couldn't help him.
These are pains that no words can describe.
Now what she's saying here will be described much better in the higher volumes, pains
that no one can describe.
She's now learning how to suffer on an infinite level because she's doing it in the divine
world.
It's no longer just physical.
It's a much higher level.
My daughter Jesus said, "Sins snatch scourges and wars from my hands.
I'm forced to allow them and at the same time I cry and suffer with the creature because
they're his own images, they're his own people."
And not only that but Jesus has died for every single one of them to save them.
And so he hates to see them destroying themselves and causing themselves to go to hell.
So he's suffering and the chastisement is to try and bring some kind of order out of
this disorder to bring somebody to light.
So Louisa said, "I felt I was dying for the pain and Jesus wanting to distract me," said,
"My daughter, don't lose heart.
This too is in my will because only the souls who live in my will can confront my justice."
Only those who live in my will have free access to share in the divine decrees and plead for
their brothers, "Whoops, look at that."
Look at it again.
Only those who live in my will have free access to share in the divine decrees and plead for
their brothers.
It's only when you're at that level in the divine will that you have the privilege that
is given only to those who live in the divine will.
Who are they, the angels and the saints?
That's why we're living a heavenly life on earth.
Those who dwell in my will are the ones who possess all the fruits of my humanity because
my humanity had its limits while my will has no limits and my humanity lived in my will
immersed in it inside and out and that's exactly what he wants us to do as well.
Now the souls who live in my will are the closest to my humanity, making my humanity
their own because I gave the divine will to them.
They can present themselves, because I gave the divine will to them, they can present
themselves before the divinity as invested with the divine will to see that your entrance
into the higher courts in heaven can only happen when you are invested with the divine
will.
We can't do it otherwise.
Otherwise we're on a much lower plane like everybody else.
So they can present themselves before the divinity as invested with the divine will
like another Jesus.
And they can disarm divine justice and they can intercede scripts of forgiveness.
Now I think that's an extraordinary expression, a script of forgiveness is that you snatch
out of the divine heart, a kind of nearly a covenant, you know what I mean, a declaration
of forgiveness where forgiveness would never happen if it wasn't snatched out of the divine
heart.
So extraordinary things did actually happen in these wars among individuals.
You can you can infiltrate or intercede for scripts of forgiveness for the perverted creatures.
Sometimes they live in my will, they live in me, which is your John 14, 20 to 21.
And since I live in everyone, they also live in everyone and for the good of all.
They live hovering in the air like the sun, that's the eagles, living high.
And their prayers, their acts, their reparations and everything they do are like rays which
descend from them for the good of all.
I want to give you John 15 verses 7 to 8.
That is my disciples will do the same works as I did when I go to the Father.
That's really amazing.
And so you see that the privilege we have of fusing into the divine will means that
in the divine will we can access everybody because the divine will is in everybody and
in everything and therefore we can influence things from the very center.
Instead of, you know, marching in a procession or getting a hundred thousand signatures to
try and get somebody to be impressed, you're way beyond that, you're on a different plane
all together, it's wonderful.
So May the 18th, 1915, just as once again, Jesus will have regard for the souls who live
in his will and for the places where these souls live.
Would you ever call her that?
And for the places where they live.
So the more people who are trying to live in the divine will, everybody in the area where
you live is being blessed and affected by it, isn't that very consoling?
And you know, they won't know you're doing it, therefore they won't thank you or anything
but it's much better to operate in complete secrecy.
Satan operates in complete secrecy, doesn't he?
He tries to get you to believe he doesn't exist.
And if you believe he doesn't exist, then he has complete freedom.
And so the Lord operates in secrecy, you don't see him either, and the battle is completely
on this higher plane and it's only when we shift into this higher plane we become much
more in touch with all the aspects of this battle.
So May the 18th, continue in my poor state, Louisa said, I felt my poor nature succumbing,
my poor nature is her body.
I'm in a state of continuous violence.
I want to do violence to my beloved Jesus, that's Matthew 11, 12.
The kingdom of God suffers violence and the violent take it by force.
Now to do violence to beloved Jesus is to force him to cut the chastisements down and
give us a bit of peace.
But he hides more so as not to be forced.
And then when he sees that I'm in the act of doing violence to him because he is hidden,
all of a sudden he makes himself seen and bursts into crying because of what miserable
humanity is suffering and notus will suffer.
Other times in a moving and almost imploring tone he tells me, daughter do not use violence
on me, my state is already violent in itself because of the grave evils that creatures
suffer and will suffer but I must give justice its rights.
You see all the attributes of God are equal.
His justice is merciful and kind.
His kindness is merciful and just.
His mercy is just.
Now when we talk to people about mercy they seem to interpret mercy as I'm being let off
the hook.
Mercy is much greater than that.
Being let off the hook doesn't help.
If letting a person who is grievously sinning off the hook sends them to hell, is that mercy?
No, mercy has to be just and it has to be kind and it has to be wise and all the rest
of it.
So all the attributes of God are manifested in the responses that God gives to us.
So let's go to the next paragraph then while he was saying this Jesus Christ and I cry
together with him many times it seems that transforming himself completely into me.
Many people call that by locating into you Jesus cries through my eyes and then all the
tragedies that Jesus has shown and during the years before human bodies mutilated floods
of blood, towns destroyed, churches profaned, passed through my mind and I remember saying
to another class something like I'm not sure if that has happened yet and the moment I
had said the word the Lord gave me a big check in my heart and said you're wrong.
It has happened.
It has happened, everything that's described here has happened as described because I don't
remember instances from the First World War, there's only one I remember because it made
such an impression on me but in the Second World War cities destroyed and blah blah blah
going on all the time and some of the destruction of World War I is unbelievable.
So Louisa said my poor heart is lacerated by the pain.
I feel it now right because of the spasm, now ice cold so at one stage I write in another
stage it's ice cold and when I suffered this I hear the voice of Jesus saying how I grieve,
how I grieve, I want to give you Ephesians 4 30, Ephesians 4 30 do not grieve the Holy
Spirit, the way we grieve the Holy Spirit is to rebel against the divine will.
Now I grieve Jesus said and he burst into sobs but who can say everything?
Now as I was in this state my sweet Jesus in order to somehow calm my fears and frights
he told me, my daughter courage, it's true that grace will be the tragedy, this is World
War I but know that I will have regard for the souls who live as we would say in my will,
the translation says of my will and for the places where these souls live.
Just as the kings of the earth have their courts and their quarters in which they keep
safe in the midst of dangers and of the fiercest enemies because the strength they have is
so great that their very enemies while they destroy other places do not even look at the
point for fear of being defeated.
In the same way, watch this now, I too, king of heaven, I have my quarters and I have my
courts upon the earth, okay?
These are the souls who live in my divine will, in whom I live and the court of heaven crowds
around them, the strength of my will keeps them safe, rendering the bullets cold and
driving back the fiercest enemies.
Now there's a lot of references I could give you to God's divine counsel, his heavenly
counsel but I want to give you Job 15 verse 8, Job 15 verse 8.
And I want to give you Jeremiah 23, 18.
Now to live in the courts of the Lord, the Sam speak about it as well, means that you
are taken into the inner sanctum.
If you remember the structure of the temple in Jerusalem, you had the large court of the
Gentiles on the outside, is that okay?
Then you had to go inside to the court of the women and then into another court, the
court of the men and the priests and that was the place where sacrifice was offered and
then you had the holy of holies, okay?
So the courts of the Lord are to be in the interior ones, not this outer one, is that
okay?
But I want to give you, for the whole paragraph, I want to give you Revelation 7 1 to 4.
Because John says that in the chastisement at the end time, that the people who truly
believe in God and trust in Him will have a mark for them to protect them from some of
the terrible things that will happen.
So Jesus said, "My daughter, why do the blessed themselves remain safe and fully happy even
when they see humanity suffer and the earth inflames?
It's precisely because they live completely in My will.
Know that I put souls to live completely in My will on the earth in the same condition
as the blessed in heaven," would you call her that one?
People who are living, truly living in divine will, are living exactly the same as the blessed
in heaven with one exception and that is on earth you can suffer and in heaven you don't.
And on earth, because you can suffer, you can merit and in heaven you don't merit because
your journey is over.
So therefore He said, "Live in My will and fear nothing, even more.
In these times of human carnage, I want you not only to live in My will, but to live among
those of your brothers between Me and them."
Now this is a very important statement that's called standing in the breach as the position
of an intercessor, standing in the breach.
And I want to give you for that Isaiah 59, 16, things were really bad at the time of
Isaiah and the Lord said, "I looked for someone to stand in the breach and I couldn't find
it."
Well if there's no one to stand in the breach, you get the full brunt of justice.
And I want to give you Psalm 106 verse 23.
And in Psalm 106 verse 23 we're told that if Moses had not stood in the breach between
God and the Israelites, that they would have been wiped out in the wilderness.
But he stood between them and he did the intercession for them.
So Jesus said, "I want you to stand between your brothers, between Me and them.
You will hold Me tightly within yourself, sheltered among the offenses that creature
send Me.
And as I give you My humanity and what I suffered as a gift, while keeping Me sheltered, you
will give your brothers My blood, My wounds, My torns, and My merits for their salvation.
I absolutely love that."
Now you'll hear her praying like that in the hours of the Passion.
But if you're not doing the hours of the Passion, you can do it in just one moment.
You can say to the Lord, "I want to fuse Myself in your holy humanity and in your
divinity.
I want to enter in, I want to take your precious blood, and I want to pour it over all the
people of Ireland who are in apostasy against you."
And I do that for their healing, for their forgiveness, for their salvation.
It only takes a moment, but it's massive what you're actually doing.
They need to really understand how massive it is because you're doing it in the divine
will.
That's what I love about the divine will prayers.
They don't have to be lengthy, but they're extremely important.
So He says, "I give you My humanity, and I give you My sufferings as a gift, and you
keep Me sheltered in your heart, and you give your brothers My blood, My wounds, My thorns,
and My merits for their salvation.
You can be saving souls all the time, and you can be saving them in huge numbers."
Okay.
I think I'll stop there because it's a quarter past.